my American drunk food is me making easy
Mac put some honey nut cheerios on that
in a little sriracha damn I want I want
to take a couple vacation days off work
and take this a Europe with me
not a bug reading the bug that's right
flick from a bug flying on chicken
listen this is an origami swan oh hell
no I can't do it what is this orange
ball sack it's not an eyeball
good job Philippines I finished it yeah
let's be real this time like Iowa or
something I'm guessing there's balls in
here who's the best balls I've ever had
in my mouth it's like this is the best
thing I've ever enjoyed in marks I once
had a meal from like a five-star chef
Brazil you got it right
shiny food what is this root Oh Oh what
the I like it I feel bad
yo why are you so nice a lot with this
dog because I'm a foodie okay
I like food community like a full Big
Mac to sober up you can is like you have
a piece of salmon that's respecting all
right yeah man oh this is like something
out of Sbarro that way a kebab what's a
donor this is really good this is way
better than a Big Mac this is a food
that's accessible to the guy that just
came out of the club I think these drunk
foods were delicious
in fact I think I'm gonna have a little
bit more right now there's not nearly as
much fried stuff as I was expecting like
American drunk food is good it's good
it's great but it's limited
I'm into all your truck foods Deena I
will I loved all the foods like if you
ever think about right now if you're in
a coma and know this is real like you're
just in the bed somewhere with like a
little blue blue going this this is like
I feel where the internet is my shell is
his face right now